the situation in Italy was not on the
agenda today but recent announcements by
the Italian government everest concern
over its over its budgetary course
concerns that need to be addressed soon
today Minister tria explained these
recent decisions and its budgetary
strategy today was not the moment for an
in-depth discussion Italy has yet to
present its full budget draft budgetary
plan by October 15 like the rest of the
member states and we will certainly come
back to this reserve all the Boesch
control visual occasions the visitor
economic issue manager Leone Pacifica's
report on to see beyond tolerant
external descriptions of us modern
kuvakin function destabilization budget
a it a social Palazzo no open Contenta
subjectiveness you know nouveau routine
suit imperative they establish what Papa
mo copia on the second point and the
larger groups afternoon deepening mu and
the role of the Commission and CSM the
cooperation between the Commission and
the SM has been good during the last few
years in debt sustainability analysis
our focus is on risks and it does not
provide policy advice which is the role
of the Commission and therefore I see no
way that in the future we would
interfere with the coordination of
economic policies which is the
prerogative of the Commission again